- So, there's something I can
show the audience right now.
- Okay, let's do it.
(applause)
- Everybody, we can all do this.
- Okay.
- So I'll show
- I gotta get
- You the thing
- prepared.
- And then I'll explain it,
you're on the edge of your seat.
- I'm competitive!
- Bebe's good to go, she's good,
she's like, I got this.
Okay so everybody just take your hand
and do a thumbs up, do a little Fonzi.
- Mmkay.
- Alright, so if you can just do that,
and then transfer the
hand to a point, okay.
And then just go back and forth,
just go back and forth, okay?
So that's relatively easy, right?
- No.
- Just, just, and then
(audience laughing)
thumb down and point,
right, and then go back.
- You can eavesdrop though,
so see that's your skill.
- Yeah, okay.
Easy enough, right?
Now, take your other hand.
(laughing)
Everyone's going, oh boy, Kegan!
With this hand, point,
and with this hand, do the thumb.
Now, and you can go as slowly as you want,
we're gonna switch back
and forth, like that.
Shaboom.
- Oh, shh, dang it.
- Shaboom, shaboom.
- I feel so not...
- Right here, you're killing it!
She is crushing it, right here.
You are, everybody look at her!
Let's see if she can do it under pressure.
She is crushing it, right, boom.
(audience shouting)
Oh no, I shouldn't have brought it!
- [Kelly] You brought the camera!
- I screwed it up!
I put pressure on you, alright.
Put the thumb up and then point,
and then flip it.
(exclaims)
(audience laughing)
And then flip it.
- I'm doing it, I'm doing it!
- Kelly's doing it!
Yep yep you're doing it, that's it!
- [Bebe] Yay!
(audience clapping)
- I'm brilliant!
I'm so smart!
- So we did this, we did this on the show,
we did this on the show
and this is an example
of what scientists call
bimanual interference.
Which is the, like a fancy term
for the trouble that your brain runs into
when you try to do two different
things at the same time
with your hands in particular.
So I guess if you're a drummer,
you're like, a genius.